yes you come in here come on say sorry  mama  I'm on Sakhalin that baby is six and  Elizondo  hi there he Anita Davis to pen yo cuz  where'd you get that jacket from yo I'll  eat a tu madre  Jessica Mira quien esta aqui - Tia  Concha  yesin it's happened to you too  I even tried tinder prema but they're  not good enough for them how could it  happen to you what were you doing all  year I I was single and  happy I think I you don't understand  yes he found  Yesi isn't he so cute he rescued a  poodle and named it to you too I even  tried tinder  you see yes II need to know you  hey fern wait guys this is my boyfriend  Steven oh hi everybody it's here it's  here  what get it  they're fine I got it yeah yeah yeah you  get it  it's here